[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to with the game of thrones TV show
now at an end I thought I'd go back and
review the major character of
differences between the source material
and its adaptation whilst george RR
martin has not finished his epic saga on
the page we can still compare the work
with the show as there's quite a lot of
differences in place throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
between characters like Catelyn Stark
Daenerys and more this is full spoilers
ahead so if you aren't fully caught up
with a book or TV show then there may be
some things that are room for you here
with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for click in this
video I hope you enjoy it now sit back
relax and let's get into the major book
and TV show differences Jon Snow
Jon Snow is a character that has had
some pretty major changes from his
personality in the source material in
the original works Jon is only just
about 16 at the beginning of it whereas
Kit Harington was about 25 when he
started filming in the works this makes
more sense as it's almost a rite of
passage that he sent to the wall whereas
in the show it just comes across as some
place that he's forced to go in addition
to this in the books
jon is a walk similar to bran and due to
this he can also possess and control
animals Jon also has the ability to see
into the future and there are several
aspects in the books that he prophesized
his foreign advance this is of course
really similar to bran and it's clear
that foolish show they switched several
aspects into brans character and gave
Jon pretty much ground-level powers and
abilities tyrion lanister next up is
Tyrion Lannister who was arguably the
most departed from his original
portrayal in this show Tyrion is wise
thoughtful and a kind man that is
willing to make major sacrifices in
order for the greater good
juxtaposing this in the novel's he sends
several characters to their death
without any guilt and when discussing
getting revenge on Cersei he states he
wishes to rape and murder her in
addition to this the books betray him as
a deformed dwarf who has one black and
one
during the Battle of Blackwater his nose
was cut up and the hideous character is
seen as grotesque by society standards
which ties into our next character che
che is far detached from her show's
counterpart but with the pry description
of Tyrion you can't really blame her in
this show it's clear that she's very in
love with Tyrion which makes her
betrayal so heartbreaking at the end
however in the novel it's clear she's
just using the character for his wealth
and status and really has no feelings
towards him Catelyn Stark Catelyn Stark
is massively massively different from
his source material version whilst up
until the red wedding things were pretty
similar
including her fate it's upon this moment
that things change massively in the
novel's her body is brought back to life
by Varrick and she spends the rest of
the series as the undead who will stop
at nothing to get revenge for those who
betrayed her at the red wedding in hail
alter ego Lady Stoneheart
she exacts revenge in a conquest to get
vengeance for a son adding more to this
Catelyn can't speak unless she holds her
throat as it was cut open and yeah
it's just very very gory Ramsay Bolton
Ramsay Bolton is arguably one of the
show's biggest villains and in the books
is even worse in the novel's Ramsay is
an ugly sloped shouldered man that takes
out his shortcomings in life on other
people he makes his wife have sex with
his dogs and also kills several of the
Bolton sons that may be a threat to his
ascension to the throne this is a bad
bad guy and he's even worse with Theon
basically the book version makes the
show look like Mother Teresa and a
sadistic side knows no boundaries as
becomes one of the biggest threats in
Westeros during his lifetime
Daenerys Daenerys arguably has one of
the biggest departures from her book
counterpart the character is described
in the stories as being the most
beautiful woman however she loses her
hair throughout the run at Duty being
burned so many times juxtaposing her
depiction in the show Dany is a total
pacifist and would definitely have no
mad queen moments as she staunchly
against her father's actions the show
did a 180 on this and it's arguably the
biggest point of contention with
and is often the motif that people go to
when criticizing the finale I think it's
pretty fair to say that our Martin will
be doing a different ending when he
eventually gets around to finishing his
work and that it won't take this route
with the burning of King's Landing not
really being in her nature we'll have to
wait and see though
but overall those are the biggest
changes from the books and the character
depictions in the show if you've got any
other differences that you think should
have been included then make sure you
leave them in the comments below as I'd
love to read them if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out the alternate ending fan
edit which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]